okay so Donald Trump is now retweeting
articles from Fox News citing unnamed
sources about what's going on in North
Korea recall that Donald Trump is
against any articles being published
where sources are not being named here
is Trump saying this at a CPAC speech um
only against the fake news media or
press Thanks
thank you have to leave that word right
I'm against the people that make up
stories and make up sources they
shouldn't be allowed to use sources
unless they use somebody's name let
their name be put out there let their
name be put out so it's sort of weird
because yesterday Donald's hungry Donald
Trump retweeted a fox news article about
North Korea which was sort of extolling
the dangers of North Korean military
actions Donald Trump retweeted this post
from Fox News as you can see the Fox and
Friends post Donald J Trump retweeted so
presumably Donald Trump believes the
context and the text of this article
what does the article say it says that
North Korea is moving anti-ship cruise
missiles to a patrol boat and who does
the article cites unnamed sources u.s.
officials with knowledge of the latest
intelligence in the region told Fox News
on Monday this is a source where the
name is not being cited this is what
Donald Trump said media outlets should
not be able to do and not only did Fox
News did it that not only did Fox News
do it Donald Trump thought were these a
lot thought it worthy enough to retweet
to his followers I'd love to see Trump
or Sarah Huckabee Sanders respond to
this because either they have to change
their position on unnamed sources or
they have to take back the fact that
they retweeted that so I guess the only
plausible explanation here is that Trump
knew who the unnamed sources were
himself in which case he would sort of
be putting out their classified
potentially secret information I guess
that's bad too which he also claims to
be against so Trump is basically making
the case for North Korean action
implicitly or at least for the danger
posed by North Korea or whatever by
retweeting articles
Fox News that site exactly the type of
sources that he says shouldn't be
allowed and there are no repercussions
for this for Donald Trump because his
voters don't hold him accountable period
and if true again if Donald Trump knows
this to be true because he knows who the
sources
he's retweeting leaks of potentially
classified information which he also
says that he is against now for the
thinking people in our audience this is
a good opportunity to talk about when to
trust unnamed or anonymous sources and
there's a really good article from
fivethirtyeight.com which we're going to
put in the video description to this
YouTube video for this story which tells
you listen not all unnamed sources are
the same unnamed is not the same as
anonymous you can also have different
specificity in terms of an unnamed or
anonymous source really good article I'm
not arguing that this is untrue but what
I'm telling you is that this violates
Donald Trump's own stated barometer for
when these types of stories should even
be written